hello ladies and gentlemen welcome to
Sunday morning science I'm very excited
about today's lesson presentation before
I get started I had I got an email this
week someone asking me if I'm still
going to continue doing my edited videos
I've got a lot of you know nice
presentations on this YouTube channel
that I do a lot of work to edit and you
know kind of perfect them so there's no
um zand butts and things like that and
they're a lot shorter I will continue
doing those but the reason that I'm
doing live shows right now is because
the past few months I things have been
crazy at work and I have no time for
video editing and one of the concerns
that that he had when he emailed me is
that because these lessons are usually
about an hour long it's hard you know
when there's little gems in them here
and there it's hard to share those with
people because I got to watch an
hour-long video so I do understand that
concern if you dear viewer would like to
edit some of my videos and do little
clips that you know maybe I talk about
irreducible complexity in one spot or I
talked about I'm going to talk today
about the evolution of lungs for example
and maybe the spot on the evolution of
lungs is really cool it should be its
own standalone video if you want to edit
that for me and send it to me that's a
little clip I would definitely
appreciate that some people have taken
stuff that I've done and put up on their
own YouTube channel and that's not ideal
because I don't get any sort of revenue
for that but that is better than nothing
so I actually don't mind if people do
that as well but I would prefer it if
you would send me clips and I can post
them here on my static casual youtube
channel so that would be absolutely
wonderful if anyone would like to do
that for me because right now really I
just I have no no time at all for video
editing but I will be continuing my
series 113 questions about evolution I
will be continuing eventually my series
on evidence for evolution in your own
back yard and so those I'll probably be
able to start doing that maybe in March
but until then I'll be doing just these
live videos so without further ado let's
look at the evolution of irreducible
complexity I've made some slides for you
here let me share my screen let me see
if there's any oh thank you for the
super chat edited videos don't get those
sweet sweet super Chad's thank you let's
see and just looking through questions
here real quick or comments all right
let me
just get started on my presentation here
so what evolved first the brain the
heart or the stomach this is a question
kind of about irreducible complexity
right and today's video was inspired by
an angry question maybe you could call
it a question by Jim Vinson on my other
YouTube channel stated clearly and he
wrote he wrote a bunch of stuff like
right here is his entire comment if you
want a screenshot that and read it later
but he he went all out and very angry
about evolution after watching my video
on the evidence for evolution where I go
over the evolution of whales
he writes hey atheists aren't you at
least a little bit curious as to why no
one has ever been able to answer my
question asking for a plausible
evolutionary order of the ten vital
organs from microbe to microbiologist
that passes the laughs test for question
marks all caps rip darwin 1851 to 2017
by Jim Henson then he goes on to say man
needs all ten of his vital organs or he
dies fact man is irreducibly complex by
definition and so these are the the ten
organs that he wants to know which
evolved first the stomach the skin the
heart the lungs the brain the upper
intestine or the small intestine the
liver the lower intestine the large
intestine the pancreas the kidneys and
he says remove just one and man dies and
bye-bye evolution I I find this stuff
adorable from people who think that they
have somehow conquered the theory of
evolution but have clearly never read a
biology textbook or understand the
basics of it now what he's talking about
here is irreducible complexity and it is
true for the most part that if you
remove one of these organs a person will
die it's not true of the lower intestine
actually there's lots of people there's
hundreds of people that are living right
now without a lower intestine
because they have Crohn's disease and
they've had their lower intestine
removed what happens there's you know
the purpose of the lower intestine is to
pull water out of your stool before it
exits your body and also salts and a few
other things and so people that have
their lower intestine removed they
actually do just fine but they have to
drink a lot more water and they have to
really manage their salt intake but yeah
people can live without that but for the
most part if you get rid of any of these
other organs you do die I mean get rid
of your brain you're dead
get rid of your lungs you're dead and so
on so the reason that I'm responding to
this question is not not because I think
that I'm going to be able to change his
mind or you know I've seen other people
respond to him in the comments and he
refuses to listen to anything that they
say people have given him great answers
on this because like I said we actually
know how all of this stuff evolved we
have a we we know quite well how this
stuff evolved and if you would bother to
read a textbook he could actually figure
this out for himself but as a general
rule if someone writes to you in all
caps they're not curious about actually
learning something so I'm not really
responding to this because I want to
respond to him I'm responding this
question because it's actually just a
really fun thing to think about what did
evolve first how did these different
structures come to exist in our bodies
and it's been it's such a fun question
to think about it's actually been you
know all week as I've I've had free time
I've been thinking about this and and
I'm reading different papers and stuff
and it's a really fun topic to study how
did these things evolve step-by-step and
how do we get the evolution of
irreducible complexity so again which
which organs came first stomachs can
heart lungs brain upper intestine liver
lower intestine pancreas kidneys think
about that do you think that you can
answer that question off the top of your
head the first thing we need to
understand to make sense of this is that
our bodies are colonies of cells you are
a colony and
this concept was first presented to us
strongly by Theodor Schwann in the 1800s
he was studying you know cells under the
microscope and he kind of pieced
together everybody else's data and he's
the guy that really just realized we are
cells we are a collection of cells that
are cooperating with each other and this
is something that's so obvious to us
today we've heard this a million times
that we don't really think about how
profound this is but this is amazing you
are a colony a colony of cells that are
working together in near perfect harmony
not perfect harmony but but near perfect
harmony Theodor Schwann did not know
this but all of the cells of your body
had the same DNA and but an eyeball cell
is very different than a liver cell so
what's going on there well division of
labor has evolved in within these
colonies and division of labor is it's
mediated by cell signaling as a fetus is
developing the cells are signalling to
each other and they are sending and
receiving signals and according to the
signals that they receive they actually
turn certain genes off and turn other
genes on and this causes cellular
differentiation this causes the
production of different tissues types of
tissues and different organs and so on
and so forth the evolution of an organ
is the evolution of division of labor
this is extremely important to
understand and it's something that's not
talked about a lot in biology and maybe
the reason for that is that the best
paper on this topic was just published
earlier this year this this paper right
here the division of labor and the
evolution of extreme specialization this
was published by guy Cooper in Stuart
West in nature and they go through here
and they look at the mathematics behind
division of labor how is it that
division of labor evolves in cells and
actually division of labor also evolves
among genes
and you know within a cell but they
looked at the mathematics behind how
this stuff happens under what situations
can division of labor evolve how is it
the cooperation evolves between cells
and between genes this paper is
absolutely wonderful
unfortunately because it's published in
nature you have to be paying nature to
read their stuff but you can actually
get it at most public libraries so if
you if you if you don't already have
like a subscription to nature you can
you can read this at the public library
so unfortunately it's stuck behind a
paywall but this paper is absolutely
amazing you know we in human societies
we divide labor as well but we do that
with our brain and we use tools like
money to help us divide labor but this
talks about how division of labor
evolves really really cool paper and
there's a link to that in the video
description I've got all the links to
everything important in the video
description here so you can check that
out later so let's talk about the
evolution of irreducible complexity
because our bodies are irreducibly
complex according to the creationist
definition of irreducible complexity so
this word irreducible complexity was
coined by Michael Behe the intelligent
design advocate so he's he's a type of
creationist and because of that a lot of
people in science don't really use it
because it was I don't know it's like a
creationist buzzword but I actually
really like the word an irreducibly
complex structure or system is any
system where if you remove one of the
parts the whole system fails and most of
our BOTS the systems in our body are
irreducibly complex you know if you
remove the heart the whole body dies you
remove the lungs the whole body dies
actually if you just think about the
lungs you need a diaphragm you need the
lungs you need two trachea all those
things need to be there working together
or else you die you get rid of one of
those that you'll die so our bodies are
filled with irreducibly complex systems
and the creationists point to this and
say oh there's no way that an
irreducibly complex system could ever
evolve because of
happens through a step-by-step process
well of course they're wrong I they're
right that evolution happens through a
step-by-step process but they're wrong
to think the irreducible complexity
cannot evolve irreducibly come
irreducible complexity evolves first
when an innovation evolves an innovation
of some kind and innovations can evolve
either through exaptation or through
division of labor but once an innovation
evolves the rest of the organism might
atrophy afterwards you know they don't
need to work so hard to do that
particular thing that the new organ does
so they will lose the ability to do that
the organism might just get bigger or
denser because now it's it's so
efficient at doing something let's say
it's really efficient because of its
kidney at removing waste from its blood
well now that the kidneys removing waste
from the blood all of the cells don't
have to work so hard to deal with this
nasty waste and sludge that they'll
constantly have to deal with and because
of that the organism can grow larger
throughout evolutionary time the cells
can get more dense and they can also be
more active the more active you are the
more waste you produce if you're a cell
and so you be in order for something to
become active first they need to evolve
a really efficient way to remove that
waste and so when a new organ evolves
that enables a population to get larger
to get denser or to become more active
and then the third way that irreducible
complexity can evolve is that the
organism might move into a previously
deadly environment so think about
division of labor in humans before we
had extreme division of labor where some
people can work as engineers they don't
have to bother with you know feeding
themselves every day they just go study
rocket science all day instead before we
had division of labor to that extent
everybody had to make their own food get
their own food they had to hunt there
too so they had to do everything on
their own but once we had a really
thorough division of labor we were
eventually able to launch
humans to live in space and that was not
possible until we had that division of
labor and so we are able to live in an
environment that was previously
completely deadly for us and if you were
to take that division of labor away from
humans our astronauts would be screwed
because nobody down at Mission Control
would be able to go to work because
they'd be busy trying to hunt and gather
and you know sew their clothing and so
on so extreme agriculture is one of the
things that humans invented through
division of labor and it's allowed us to
dramatically increase our populations so
the u.s. population right now is about
three hundred and twenty five point
seven million and our our best estimates
of the pre Columbus population in in the
United States was about 3.8 million so
the Native Americans at their peak were
about 3.8 million strong so we think
there is another estimate that puts out
at 18 million but either way they were
far less dense their populations were
far less dense than ours are now today
there were certain civilizations native
civilizations that were pretty dense
even close to being on par with us and
they did a lot of agriculture and so on
but for the most part they needed they
required a lot of land to sustain a
small family or a small group and I'm
not saying that what we have now is
better but what we have now allows us to
to live in much more dense populations
and because of that our societies are
irreducibly complex this is the city of
Montreal this is where I now live
actually I live across the river from
Montreal but if you were to take out the
roads of Montreal and stop goods from
coming in and out I mean you might also
have to take out the ships but the
shipping systems but if you were to do
that the entire city would die if you
were to take out electricity the entire
city would die if you were to destroy
the bank system the entire city would
die we we don't know what to do without
money we don't know how to interact with
each other if you were to just
the farms that supply us with food here
we would die this city is an irreducibly
complex system and it emerged and we
know that it emerged gradually right
just a little bit of evidence of this
back in 1998 there was an ice storm and
it knocked out electricity for seven
days and just just seven days without
electricity all hell broke loose in
Montreal people had to flee their homes
and go into shelters that were they were
run by generators and it was a state of
emergency
people had people were accidentally
lighting their houses on fire because I
didn't know how to use their fireplaces
properly they didn't you know they've
been so used to electricity
some people were suffocating from smoke
inhalation people were dying from the
cold it was absolutely horrible seven
days without electricity go back in time
a little bit and people were living here
just fine this is a a group of people of
people of the Iroquois nation and they
Iroquois were here in Montreal and lived
here for forever without electricity
just fine and they were able to do that
because their population was very loose
very small compared to ours we're now
way too dense so now we are irreducibly
complex but we weren't always that way
sea sponges are animals that live just
fine without hearts they don't need you
know if you if you take the heart out of
a human we die but if you take the heart
out of a sponge they're fine they don't
actually have a heart and the reason for
that is that the ocean is their blood it
brings them nutrients and it takes away
the waste products for them their cells
are very loosely packed they're not
nearly as dense as our bodies which is
you know a sponge is full of holes and
their cells don't do much work compared
to ours ours we have these mussels
especially our mussels do a lot of work
and produce a lot of waste and so we
need a very efficient way to remove that
way
the sponges don't don't need that so
there's a lot of pros to living like
this living a simple life of a sponge
there's also a lot of cons one is that
you can't live outside of the
nutrient-rich seas and you can't play
video games so there's there's some cons
to that fish live just fine without a
large intestine and the reason for that
is that the purpose of the large
intestine as we mentioned earlier is to
pull water out of your stool and give
that back to the body well fish live in
the water they don't really need to
conserve water and so they don't have a
large intestine and they survive just
fine they just have a small intestine
well so that's the evolution of
irreducible complexity we know that
irreducible complexity irreducible
complexity can evolve through steps we
see this happen with human societies
irreducibly complex societies exist and
the same thing happens with organs the
evolution of an organ is the evolution
of division of labor so which came first
the stomach the skin the heart the lungs
the brain the upper intestine the liver
the lower intestine the pancreas or the
kidneys well unfortunately organs don't
fossilize well sometimes we do get some
hints in the fossil record as to what
types of organs an animal had but for
the most part we don't so how do we
answer this question how can we even
think about this sort of a thing well
the answer is we can use phylogeny by
comparing different organisms that we
are related to we can actually watch the
evolution of different organs evolve and
when we're doing this we're doing
comparative anatomy of modern organisms
that shared a common ancestor at a split
other knee
I guess before I continue real quick
here is are there any pressing questions
no okay
got Marilyn here helping me out she's if
you got any pressing questions
particularly to make it easier you can
do at stated casually and that makes it
highlight and orange so it's easy for me
to see here we go so we can use
phylogeny to figure this out
and one of the things you might be
thinking is how how can we use phylogeny
to figure out how an organ evolved
because aren't all of the animals alive
today haven't they all been evolving
just as long as we have the answer to
that question is yes but evolution is
not directional and that's really
important for understanding us because
we are extremely complex animals but
evolution doesn't always pull things
towards complexity evolution actually
usually maintains or organisms at the
current level of complexity
sometimes evolution actually pulled back
causes things to lose complexity so this
is a cave fish right here and you can
see he has no eyes he lost his eyes
because he'd been living his ancestors
had been living in the dark for so long
that the eyes were useless in the dark
and actually they were just dangerous to
have because the eye is extremely
susceptible to injury and infection so
fish that just didn't have eyes that
were born with mutations that made their
eye is smaller or had skin growing over
them and eventually mutations that got
rid of the eyes completely those fish
happened to be more fit for their
environment than the fish that had eyes
so sometimes evolution causes things to
get simpler with time sometime usually
it causes them to stay the same
sometimes natural selection will pull
things towards greater levels of
complexity and Richard Dawkins has a
wonderful video about this called you
can find it on YouTube if you look up
Richard Dawkins demonstrates the
evolution of the eye
he talks about climbing mountain
probable which is one of the books at he
wrote and he's doing this talk at the
Royal Society and he he talks about the
evolution of the eye and there's all
sorts of different eyes in the animal
kingdom and he he's focusing he talks
about all the different stages that the
evolution of the eye went through and he
talks about the Nautilus the Nautilus is
this critter right here that looks kind
of like an octopus but losing a shell
and they've got a really cool eye and
you know our eyes have a lens that helps
focus light back on the retina the
Nautilus does not have a lens it's got a
pinhole eye and so here on this diagram
here I've got a couple different eyes
that exist in the animal kingdom and the
in the mollusk group of animals and this
one right here is the water filled
cavity eye with a pinhole instead of a
lens and a pinhole eye is really neat
because it allows a pinhole can actually
focus light on a retina in a way sort of
similar to a lens your letting light in
through a tiny little spot and so that
that allows you to get sharp images a
lens a lens lets the hole get bigger and
you can still have a nice sharp image
and the benefit of a lens that you can
get let a lot more light in and still
have a nice clear picture so the
Nautilus is at a disadvantage compared
to the eyes of an octopus which have a
lens the Nautilus is at a disadvantage
because it needs a lot of light in order
to see its but it can see nice and clear
it just needs a lot of light if it had a
lens it could do the same thing but with
much less light so it would be at a huge
advantage if it would evolve a lens but
there's a problem here when you have a
pinhole eye it works super well and the
only way to evolve a lens from a pinhole
eye is for skin to grow over the eye
hole and that of course because skin
cells are not perfectly clear that would
be a disadvantage for the Nautilus in
most environments
it's got this nice pinhole eye and it
can see just fine if one were to be born
with skin over its eye even a really
thin piece of skin that's that's pretty
clear that would be a disadvantage
because it's still got a small pinhole
and now it's got some gunk covering that
pinhole that's that's a disadvantage but
if you change the environment just a
little bit let's say that you add a
parasite that can get into that eye and
eat the eat the retina well now you have
a selective advantage for any individual
that's born with a cover over Ed's eye
it is gonna be able to slip it's gonna
be able to see slightly less well but
it's it's not going to be susceptible to
that parasite and so it change in the
environment like this can actually allow
skin to grow over that eye and then
future mutations can cause that skin to
become more and more clear and then
future mutations can cause that skin to
bulge and form a lens and so this is how
we get the evolution of complexity
through these really strange situations
but for the most part evolution is
natural selection is forcing animals to
maintain their current current structure
I got it I got a question just yesterday
someone asked if n fib Ian's are
evolving towards a more land-loving
lifestyle RN fib Ian's eventually going
to come out on the land and the answer
to that is no and fib Ian's for the most
part most amphibians natural selection
is keeping them exactly how they are any
changes to the left or to the right end
up being selected against because
they're really good at living in the
environments that they're living in
right now but there are a couple of
individual species you know desert
desert desert toads for example which
natural selection is really pushing them
to be more and more capable on land and
in really dry environments and so it is
possible that you know these desert
toads for example might eventually be
able to leave water for good right now
desert toads
still have to lay their eggs and water
aside from that they can pretty much
live like a lizard on dry land but they
have they need water they need puddles
to lay their eggs in so not some species
will dig and find water that way to lay
their eggs in but amphibians are tied to
the water because of the way that their
eggs work but you could eventually in
the future get a group of these frogs to
you know end up evolving an egg that
does not dry out and be laid right on
the land that's definitely a possibility
and in fact that is what happened in the
past there was a small group of
amphibians that branched off from the
main group because they went on to land
and they ended up giving rise to all of
the reptiles and birds and mammals so
that has happened in the past but most
of the amphibians stayed in the water
and they're still there and because of
that because evolution is not
directional we can actually use
phylogeny to see how different organs
evolved because most organisms are still
living fairly close to the way that they
were
when these organs first started evolving
and if we compare all the different
creator critters on the family tree we
can piece together how these organs
evolved just as evidence that increases
in complexity are rare that most things
stay the same bacteria are 35 times
heavier than all animals combined if you
dry them out and just weigh their carbon
the dry weight of bacteria is 35 times
heavier than the dry weight of all
animals combined so bacteria the
simplest among the simplest creatures on
earth are the among the most effective
they are doing the best they are the
most prevalent and there's this
wonderful paper right here called the
biomass distribution on earth that I
recommend looking up it is free it's
completely free and there's tons of
really cool information in there so I
recommend checking that out the biomass
distribution on earth super-fun
anyway comparative anatomy here we go so
we're gonna we're gonna start looking at
single-celled eukaryotes a particular
group of single-celled eukaryotes called
Co NL flagellates well first of all are
there any big questions I should answer
before I move on yeah it's from Jay he
says the same trait can evolve several
times in separate species the trade fits
to the environment and there are several
spots on earth that have a same
environment right right so so what he's
talking about I don't know if you're
able to hear that but it was mentioned
that traits can evolve multiple times
and it's the environment that can select
for those traits and this is true this
is actually one of the problems with
comparative anatomy one of the
difficulties with comparative anatomy is
that sometimes a trait will evolve more
than once but through very carefully
studying how a trait emerges when you
when you look at embryos you can
actually tell a lot of times whether or
not an organ evolved twice through
what's called convergent evolution or if
it evolved once and we have inherited a
different version of that that old organ
so we're gonna look at the kidneys for
example today in hagfish and the kidneys
and Lance a--let's Lance let's also have
a kidney like structure they have an
organ that helps filter their internal
fluids but it's not really related to a
kidney at all he uses a totally
different process it emerges from a
different part of the body but hagfish
have a structure that's some people
would argue it's not really a kidney but
it's it is the start of a kidney and
it's using the same mechanisms that our
kidneys used today and it's using the
same genes that our kidneys use today to
do what it does and because of that we
consider it to be a legitimate kidney
not just analogous to a kidney but
homologous to a
I'm kidney so if it's if it's homologous
that means that it it's actually a
primitive version of the modern
structure if it's analogous it means
that it's a separately evolved structure
and scientists who study who do
comparative anatomy they spend a lot of
time trying to figure out is this organ
homologous or analogous to the ones that
other organisms have and this is is it
this has been a huge part of biology
which is really taking off now with
genetics and with what's called evo-devo
the study of evolutionary development we
can actually we can tell really clearly
now whether or not a structure evolved
through convergent evolution or and
actually one one organ evolved from a
previous organ that we see elsewhere in
the family tree so Quanah flagellates
these are single-celled organisms they
live in the ocean I think there's some
freshwater species as well they have a
big long tail a flagella this is
different than the bacterial flagella by
the way because these are eukaryotic
single-celled organisms their tail
oscillates instead of spins but they can
swim around and live their lives as a
free living individual or they can pair
up with partners and form multi-celled
structures and they do so depending on
what types of food are around them and
scientists who study this have found
that the cell signals that they use the
signaling that they send to each other
is the same as the cell signaling used
in our cells
well it is slightly different but the
there's a handful of genes that they use
that are the same as the genes that that
ourselves used to signal to each other
and for for differentiation and for
sticking to each other our cells stick
to each other as well just like these
guys do and so this group of organisms
is extremely fascinating to biologists
that want to understand the origin of
multicellular cellular organisms because
these guys can live as individual
or as multi-celled organisms their skin
is their mouth so you know what we
wanted to know how skinny bald and have
the mouth or have the stomach evolved
their skin is their skin and it's their
stomach they through endocytosis
they absorb food particles through their
skin they form these little these little
balls that that capture the food and
through exocytosis they excrete waste
out into the water and it's the same
process in Reverse so there's a packet
with waste in it and that packet goes to
the cell membrane goes to the skin of
the cell and then it excretes that so
these things have no organs really
they're just single cells and their skin
and their stomach is literally the same
thing going on to sponges sponges are
their lineage goes back to the earliest
animal fossils that we have one yeah the
earliest animal fossil that we have is a
sponge
it's way before the Cambrian and sponges
have very simple cellular
differentiation they they have some
cells that still have their little tails
just like these come on a fabulous deal
and some of their cells don't have tails
some of their cells just act as body
support and these cells feed each other
so they're cooperating with one another
to form these giant three-dimensional
structures and they wiggle their little
flagella and they pump water there's
their body is spongy and they suck water
through all these holes all throughout
their body they're collecting food that
passes through and then that water spits
out these tubes that we see here and
that's see sponges there's very simple
cellular differentiation and if you look
here at the structure of a of a sponge
you see that the cells that are that are
used for feeding are almost identical to
those cono flagellates those those
single-celled organisms that we saw
earlier and by the way we have
like this in our body as well they're
actually a little bit different now but
we still use the same flagella we use
them we call them cilia they're in our
lungs but they're the exact same
structure they're in our intestines in
our lungs they're all over the place
these little hairs that wiggle around
and in our lungs it's it's used to get
phlegm out of our lungs and so on and so
forth so with the with the Kawano
flagellates there's really no difference
between the skin and the stomach and the
same is still pretty much true for the
sponge there is cellular differentiation
but the the stomach you could say is
kind of spread all out amongst the skin
and the the body cells everything's all
kind of mixed there's no clear
differentiation between the stomach and
the skin and cnidarians we have we
finally get the division between skin
and stomach and these animals are really
funny because they're their mouth and
their anus is actually the same organ
they swallow things and then regurgitate
them afterwards but their gut is on the
inside
they've got very highly specified cells
on the inside for digesting food they
excrete digestive enzymes and then they
absorb food and then they feed the rest
of the cells of the body so they pass
nutrients from cell to cell and then you
have the outside of the animal which is
just you know that's that's where it's
skin is so here you finally have a clear
differentiation between the gut and the
skin and so our question I was asking
what what organ evolved first the skin
or the gut well they actually evolved at
the same time because they're actually
the division of one thing the skin and
the gut were one thing and then they
divided into two things and cnidarians
by the way this is a group of animals it
includes all jellyfish all anemones and
corals and that's where we get the
evolution
of the gut and the skin and it's also
where we start to see the evolution of
the brain we don't have a brain yet
you've probably heard that jellyfish
don't have brains instead anemones and
jellyfish they have what are called
nerve nets they do have nerves and their
nerves are very similar to ours in fact
they use the same proteins for cell
signaling between the between different
nerves and so on but they don't have a
brain that it's not it hasn't condensed
into one area of the body yet
so there we finally have the evolution
of the skin and the stomach and actually
technically we call it the gut because
it's not really differentiated into a
stomach yet so it's the skin and the gut
and the nerve net next moving closer to
us on the family tree we have
hemichordates and hemichordates
are very special worms there they're
very similar to us they're strikingly
similar to us here on the right we have
some hemichordate poop these things are
found again in the Precambrian so before
the Cambrian explosion
we have trace fossils that these things
were existing these these little tubes
of feces here sand like feces we find
these in the fossil record before the
Cambrian explosion we don't have clear
examples of actual fossilized
hemichordates but we we have all the
signs that they existed and one of their
major innovations they've got a mouth
and they've got an anus so that's nice
you don't have to use the same hole for
both functions and they have a coelom
and a coelom is just a body cavity that
exists it's it's a liquid filled cavity
that exists between the digestive tract
I've got the digestive tract there in
green there's a cavity between that and
the outer tissues of the body and this
is really neat because this allows these
organisms once that evolved these
organisms were able to get much larger
than their ancestors were
and they're able to be much more active
than their ancestors were and the reason
for that is that this liquid allows the
gut to digest food and then squirt
nutrients into this liquid and that
liquid within that liquid that nutrients
can dissipate and reach every part of
the body it's like a really primitive
blood system and that allows all of the
body to receive nutrients from the gut
and so the gut doesn't have to be these
cells don't have to work super hard to
pass nutrients from one cell to the next
this can happen passively through this
liquid in the sea them these guys also
evolved to what are kind of like blood
vessels inside their bodies and you know
the the coelom is open so they have an
open circulatory system but there are
some tubes in there and these tubes
allow when that when the worm is moving
around that kind of allows the that
liquid to squish around inside the body
and it sort of gets pumped they don't
have hearts and I'm a true heart but the
this that little head of this worm the
vessels go into that head and that when
the head moves it kind of pumps things
like a heart so they're they're kind of
on their way to having a circulatory
system they don't really have one yet
but they just got this open circulatory
system a really basic one so there
you've got the proto blood and proto
blood vessels forming moving forward two
simple chordates how are we doing on
time okay I've got 15 minutes
I try to keep these under an hour but
here we have this simple chordates and
there's all kinds of cool innovations
that have happened in them
these are LAN slits and they have a
brain so the the worm we were looking at
earlier it has a little bit denser
neural net then the jellyfish has but
here we actually have a chordate means
it has a nerve running that one's back
and it also has the beginnings of a
brain now we actually didn't think that
they had a brain for a long time it was
just recently that we realized that they
do have a brain they had the beginnings
of a brain and we realized this by
studying the gene expression in these
animals they actually have a forebrain
and a hindbrain and then the spinal cord
but we weren't able to tell that until
we actually looked at the molecules that
these these nerves are using so this is
officially nowadays this is officially
where we say that the brain evolves is
in very simple chordates excuse me the
other early cool innovation in these
chordates is that they have a proto
liver now it's very different from our
liver it's not like its own separate
organ it's actually just a pocket in the
digestive tract but it's doing all sorts
of things that a liver does you know our
liver one of its main functions is to
take in molecules that are otherwise
toxic and break those apart metabolize
really nasty chemicals and the this
proto liver here does that for this
animal and it does all sorts of other
things that livers do today and so we
consider this to be a proto liver that
the first origins of the liver last but
not least this thing has nice blood
vessels that are very similar to the
blood vessels in modern fish but there
is no heart the blood vessels themselves
have muscles in them and the blood
vessels can contract and you might know
that today our
our arteries or veins that contract it's
the arteries yeah the arteries in our
bodies also contract and this mechanism
can be this first emerged in these very
simple chordates Precambrian times this
is a long long time ago that this stuff
this stuff first started to evolve but
there is no heart here yet
but there is this really nice blood
vessel system there are still some parts
of their circulatory system that are
open just like the worms were so these
the blood vessels will just go into a
body cavity there's big sinuses where
the the blood I'm saying blood in quotes
here because there's no blood cells yet
it's just liquid but we're getting a
really nice vascular system evolving
here already really cool moving forward
to the jawless vertebrates this is a
hagfish and I think these fish are super
cool they excrete all kinds of mucus out
of their skin if you try and catch one
with your hands it'll just coat itself
in slime they're really gross weird
animals but in their bodies they have a
legitimate liver I mean it's it's
there's no doubt that this is a liver
it's doing the same things that the the
proto liver was doing but it's now doing
them and I'm much more in a manner much
more similar to ours their brain is very
developed and they also have the first
heart the the the earliest example of a
heart they actually have four hearts not
just one but one of their hearts is
special and that it works the same way
that ours do in a way that's very
similar to ours the rest of their hearts
use just muscles of the body
but that heart in the middle there that
I'm highlighting here that's using
legitimate cardiac tissue it's involved
some very very special cell signaling
mechanisms so that it acts very similar
to our heart now this animal has very
low blood pressure compared to modern or
other other vertebrates more advanced
for it
but it does have a heart it pumps its
blood and its circulatory system is it
still is open there are some areas that
have big just you know pockets where the
blood fills but its circulatory system
has is much more complete than the other
circulatory systems that we've looked at
and there are legitimate blood cells
there's hemoglobin it's a very primitive
version of hemoglobin but there is
hemoglobin here also they have a proto
kidney and this kidney works in a way
very similar to ours and now it's it's
spread out and it's messy it's not these
nice neat little organs like we have but
they do have a proto kidney and that
filters their blood and it pulls out
nasty chemicals and spits that out into
the cloaca to be excreted by the body
last but not least it has a proto
pancreas the pancreas in humans creates
digestive enzymes at one end and it
creates regulatory hormones at the other
end into the blood and there is in
humans it's a very distinct organ but in
these jawless vertebrates it's kind of
spread out in different patches
throughout the digestive tract so it's
not a full-on legitimate organ yet but
these cells are starting to the cells
that produce these enzymes are starting
to form organ like structures and this
is how this is how organs evolve they
they evolved by the division of labor
right so moving on we've got
cartilaginous fishes so these are things
like sharks and rays and they're they're
a very very early group of fish they
split off very early on the way towards
land animals and they have the
first legitimate stomach and the first
legitimate small intestine so remember
before we said that animals had a gut
and actually if you look it if you look
at the jawless vertebrates they really
just have a gut it's just one big long
you could call it an intestine or you
could call it a stomach it's it's
neither it's kind of both it's just one
big long thing but in these
cartilaginous fishes you have the
division of the small intestine and the
stomach and the stomach is specialized
now for being highly acidic and
squeezing food and breaking it into
pieces and the intestine is specialized
for absorbing those molecules after
they've been after the food's been
broken up so you have this division of
labor instead of doing doing all the
Smashing and all the absorbing you have
one spot for smashing and dissolving and
one spot for absorbing and that's a huge
advance that dramatically increase the
efficiency of these animals so the small
intestine and the stomach are very
clearly differentiated in those fish
finally we have bony fishes the
evolution of bony fishes and this
believe it or not is where lungs evolved
and you might think what the heck that
you're showing a coral reef fish no
that's what I I'm forgetting the name of
that fish right now I used to have one
of my aquarium surgeon I'm not reading
his name but it has it doesn't have
lungs and so you might be like what the
heck why are we using this for the
evolution of lungs well it has a swim
bladder and what we found is that very
early on in the evolution of bony fishes
they evolved lungs and it appears that
the lung evolved as fish moved into
really nasty waters along the shores
where bacteria had been consuming a lot
of the oxygen that that was around and
so this was just stagnant water
decomposing plant material and so on
caused the water to be stagnant and so
these fish would have been up at sir
this sucking up air and mixing that with
water to push that over their gills and
that that was the only way to survive in
that really nasty water well the inside
of your mouth is covered in blood
vessels and those blood vessels can
actually absorb oxygen as well and so
what we think happened is that by doing
this if you had a goldfish and its water
has gone stagnant you've probably seen
this happen he's up at the top of his
bowl grime and air and shoving it
through his gills this would have been
very similar to what was happening in
the past and eventually a larger pocket
would have evolved in the back of the
throat for absorbing this oxygen the
actual oxygen instead of having to wet
it first and pass it through the gills
you would get the evolution of a larger
oxygen absorbing organ and then
eventually you would get the these
entire bubbles these these entire organs
that can fill up with air and inhale and
exhale eventually evolved and we think
that all early bony fish had lungs full
on legitimate lungs in a small group
those maintained until today so on the
right I have a it's called a pitcher
fish I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
that correct but these things can
actually live on land and here in
Montreal there isn't a there's a
researcher that raises them on land she
actually they don't normally live on
land but she raises them on land and
just makes it super humid in their
little environment and they'll like walk
around and it's really cool they just
live their whole lives on land there's a
video in the in the video description
there's a link that you can go watch a
video about those guys but these things
are they have a really ancient
connection to the early lung fish they
still have their lungs and most other
fish those have sense
evolved into a swim bladder so the swim
bladder that goldfish had the swim
bladder that most aquarium fish have
that actually is derived from ancient
lung
but some fish kept those lungs until
today here is an example of those loans
in a surgery this is that the same fish
is walking around on land here this is a
surgery showing you the lungs there's
the right lung and the left lung and
that's what they breathe with they can
breathe on land with those things they
don't they also have gills but they
don't need to use them they can just get
air from the oxygen from the air last
but not least we have tetrapods so these
one group of these lung fish these lung
lobe-finned fish came out on to land and
gave rise to tetrapods tetrapods are all
the land animals with four legs and
lungs and a backbone and even in early
and fib Ian's we find the evolution of
the last organ of question here and that
is the large intestine the large
intestine evolves appears to have
evolved in early early and fib Ian's all
tetrapods almost all tetrapods have them
I should point out that the evolution of
new structures in the digestive tract
and the evolution you can gain them and
lose them fairly easily we actually
watch this happen in real-time there's a
group of reptiles or put on an island
and they evolved the new chamber and
their intestines really quickly because
most of the food on that island was a
vegetable matter and they had previously
specialized on insects and to facilitate
the digestion of vegetable matter a new
structure inside the intestines ended up
evolving I had got that backwards a new
structure inside the intestines evolved
and that facilitated the digestion of
vegetation for them so this can actually
happen a lot and there are some
amphibians that have kind of lost their
large intestine but we think that the
ancestor of all tetrapods developed one
and what that enabled this ancestor to
do is to live on dry land for larger
lengths of time because the large
intestine allows the reabsorption of
water from the digestive tract and so it
helps you so you don't dry out so there
we have it which organ evolves first
skin stomach brain liver heart kidney
pancreas upper intestine lungs or lower
intestine well if we look at our family
tree here and do a little bit of
comparative anatomy we can actually
figure that out that not perfect
certainty but a fairly high degree of
certainty and the reason that there are
some doubts is because of course
throughout evolutionary time an organ
can evolve and then be lost and so we
might think that something didn't evolve
until you know vertebrates but in fact
it evolved earlier but was lost and all
the ancestors so there is some degree of
an uncertainty here but we can be pretty
certain that the answer to this question
is this order right here the skin and
stomach evolved at the same time
actually then the brain evolved in these
primitive chordates then we have the
liver that evolves then we have the
heart and after the heart we have the
kidneys and you might be wondering you
know the heart and kidneys on our family
tree they appear at the same time they
appear in the in the hagfish but we know
that the heart must have evolved first
because kidneys required blood pressure
in order to work the kidney works by
shoving liquid from the blood through
very small tubes and you need blood
pressure in order to do that and so
either the heart had to move all first
or really strong artery arteries that
could pulsate so most likely the heart
evolved first there but on that question
there is some ambiguity may be the
kidneys of all-first when you had these
really strong arteries that could pump
blood
but most likely it was the heart than
the kidneys then we have the pancreas
which evolved and again the pancreas
first emerged as this protoman crease
that was very spread out then we have
the upper intestine then we have the
lungs then we have the lower intestine
and that is the order in which things
evolved so that does it for time but I
would like to answer questions so let me
just go back to hello again let me pull
up questions if there are any is there
anything we really need to address there
[Music]
yeah well look what I do you see one
question are they like like lampreys yes
they are they're very similar lampreys
and and hagfish are extremely similar
and also Oh from sorry I'm gonna say
your name wrong epic if a gained word
water lettuce thank you for the super
chat I appreciate it
let's see sorry what was the interesting
question that you heard the comment
these had gastrointestinal tract
protesting food was the number one
priority yeah yeah processing food was
the number one priority and as we saw
the the stomach the gut evolved before
the brain so yeah that is very
fascinating
cool well I think
[Music]
junker Zn says should we throw more
complexity into the works by talking
about gene expression previously evolved
and then lost mechanisms can re-express
more quickly later if they are needed
again yeah that so that's true I mean
the evolution of an organ is the
division of labor and the division of
labor is really facilitated by
communication between cells and so once
a communication system evolves even if
that organ ends up going away
throughout evolutionary time it is
easier for something similar to that
organ to reappear because the
communication mechanisms between those
cells do still exist and a lot of cases
not not every case sometimes though
they'll just get completely lost
throughout evolutionary time but yeah
you do get what are called atavisms
atavisms I think I'm saying that right
where an old structure will just pop up
in an animal one example of this there's
a dolphin that has hind legs well it's
got fins where the hind legs would be
there's Adam isms in horses
- you'll get horses with extra toes a
horse just walks on its middle fingers
and the middle finger toe but you'll get
a divisa more a horse will be born with
three fingers instead of just one so
that that happens quite a bit vibrant
Lee says serious question what kind of
fish was that when you were showing
their lungs was it ace was it a
snakehead that was the the [ __ ] here
I'm probably saying it wrong bi CH i ere
i are fish and there's a video about
those guys in the video description you
can check that out someone says before
the heart evolved how did species
procreate without love you know I guess
there were all just animals let's see
alright I think that wraps it up for
questions anything else that we missed
or should talk about Marilyn
I think that sums it up no well thank
you for coming again if someone wants to
cut out pieces of that and make some
little highlight videos that would be
awesome just email me John jo-ann at
stated clearly calm and we can you know
I can send you the video file for this
and you can hack it up and make little
clips and again it's not a huge deal if
this stuff shows up on other YouTube
channels I'm not gonna flip out about
that but I would prefer to have it sent
to me that'd be awesome
so thank you I will see you next week
so long